also today three Mariachi groups going
to be strumming and strutting at the
Water Street Plaza Amphitheater in
Henderson for their Dia de los Muertos
this includes the nation's first the
all-female mariachi band and two local
high school groups tickets are 15 in
advance and twenty dollars at the door
performances start tonight at seven they
will have a couple of food vendors on
hand by the way uh here in town the
Springs preserves Dia de los Muertos
event is sold out so head on down to
Henderson if you're looking for some
mariachi
while the flm cactus garden lighting is
tonight No Reservations are required
this year but they are stay they're
staggering guests to prevent
overcrowding so you may have to wait in
line the entry fee is just one dollar
per person the money will be donated to
local charities and as always you can
enjoy the lights photos with Santa and a
food truck fit for chocolate lovers the
fun starts at 7 00 PM Nate you're
already dressed for the occasion of the
deal dos Muertos I sure am I brought my
Dia de los Muertos bow tie and it's kind
of a fancy schmancy one with some skulls
on it some skulls yeah check it out
except we need a it's also monical to
say oh there we go oh how cool is that
[Laughter]
that's really cool yeah I like that good
good stuff thank you